now you have Aamir Khan shuttle Khan
these are really big names right yes
what are they doing taking selfies
hanging out with Modi I mean are they
like ambassadors to the cause of trying
to stop the impression is that what's
going on this is not again I will repeat
one more time this is not a Hindu most
versus Muslim thing because I don't want
anybody to misinterpret that you got 8
million people's dogs or cats whatever
locked up imagine what kind of uproar
that would be the people who killed
Gandhi now these other people are trying
to kill Muslims yes the same people
Aamir Khan and Shahrukh Khan today do
they have a responsibility as being
people who are that popular they're
famous this is the supremacist ideology
the nationalistic militant ideology
against the good people Smita
hamdulillah assalamualaikum greetings of
peace welcome to the Deen show and I
want people to imagine that an occupying
force came over locked you in your homes
took away TV internet not just that
because sometimes we we need to stay
away from these things anyway but an
oppressive regime came over locked you
in your homes and you weren't able to go
out of your house you're stuck in there
and the siege is going on how many days
now about a hundred days hundred days
yes people are still locked that we're
talking about Kashmir we're talking
about Kashmir here and yes people are
locked in
since the revocation of article 370
there has not stopped that has not
stopped people are in curfew curfew does
get off from what we hear but people are
still in a lockdown a curfews that means
they can leave their house there are
certain hours as we understand it that
they can leave their house but
businesses are still shut down and
basically people are in a lockdown the
communications is still to a very large
extent shut down the landlines we hear
has come up but people cannot
communicate to the outside world we have
heard and we continue to hear from our
contacts that people who are you know
our friends here were from Kashmir
they're not able to
connect with their families at least the
first two and a half months or so they
were not able to connect even through
second or third channels now at least
because some of the landlines are up
people are able to talk but there is
really no open communication you will
not find out what is happening in
Kashmir because they still continue to
be in the lockdown for over 100 days now
almost and these are not like curfew for
kids like be home at a certain time
we're trying to keep the kid you know
kids off the street this is like adults
this is and and I did say occupying
force this is an occupying they've
occupying these people's land now how
does that work if I if I'm using the
right terminology so so let me take a
step back here let me give you a little
bit of history on Kashmir right so
Kashmir since India and Pakistan the
partition happened when British sure's
left India there was Kashmir without
getting into too much details of you
know what happened across the country
specifically for Kashmir what happened
was there was an article 370 what that
meant was this as part of Indian
Constitution that people from outside
shmear cannot buy land in Kashmir
Kashmir will have their own sort of a
government which the defense has taken
care of by India and the rest of the
matters are with the people of Kashmir
and what happened was 100 days ago the
government of India kind of relocated
that article 370 that is in itself is
going against the Constitution of India
and then on top of that people have been
in the lockdown if you know India is
saying it's it's good for Kashmir then
then people should be open people should
be free they should be able to do what
they need to do and they should be happy
if you know the government claims that
this is a good thing for Kashmiri okay
if it's a good thing for Kashmir let the
people be out there and let the people
you know celebrate if that's the case
why are they in the curfew first of all
revocation of article 370 was a spur
Indian law it's unconstitutional and
this is from the grandson of Gandhi and
this kind of brings up to another point
but the grandson of Gandhi he himself
spoke a few days ago where he clearly
called that out that they know the
revocation of article 370 itself was
unconstitutional okay so we painted a
little picture just to get people
because most people have no idea what's
going on over there so imagining you now
you're locked in your homes for so many
days like like people would like imran
khan president of pakistan pakistan i
think he mentioned in his speech in
front of the united nations that if you
had what 8 million animals were bring a
purse like that people would have done
something people have taken a stamp
these are 8 million human beings so
hopefully people have a better picture
now and then we'll get into who are you
and your involvement in creating a very
awareness in in this effort effort now
that you're doing to try to what mo has
motivated you to get out there and
that's what you're doing creating
awareness on the situation the reality
on the ground in India and in Kashmir my
name is Junaid Junaid Ahmed I was born
in India I moved here when I was in high
school I have so since then I've been
pretty much out of touch if you want to
call it from from you know pretty much
you know living since since then living
here in the United States I did my
college here and that is why I got
involved just to make people aware and
keep in mind I want to I want to very be
very clear and specific in one one point
here this is not when people talk about
India and Pakistan will talk about
things within India people think it is a
in Hindu versus Muslim issue I want to
let you know I grew up in India this is
not a Hindu versus Muslim issue majority
of Hindus are amazing good people well
some of my good friends are Hindus my
lot of my co-workers are Hindus Hindu by
definition is a very good peaceful
people
now the ideology we are talking about
here is the supremacist ideology taking
into background RSS Russia is a rock
song
the RSS and its sister organizations
that is what they're introducing
divisive mentality people you know
hatred
you know oppression against minorities
that is the concern that is the issue
that should be talked about it is not a
Hindu versus Muslim issue and keep in
mind these are the same people who
killed Gandhi are their voices on the
ground of Hindus who are coming up let
let's say for instance a lot of these uh
actors out there what do you know the
cons I'm a climber Khan Shah Rukh Khan
yeah and how about those are but those
are Muslim actors right they are they
are people like them but how about Hindu
actors or just Hindu Hindu personalities
people because it's just blatant this is
just blatant evil that's being
perpetuated are there people on the
ground these good people who are coming
out and speaking out against this
oppression that's a very good question
and I have a very short answer and I'll
dwell into that the answer is yes there
are a lot of good people on the ground
there are a lot of good voices on the
ground and people are speaking up yeah
so people are taking a stance people are
taking whatever means that they have now
having said that let me tell you what is
happening to those people
unfortunately because they these forces
have penetrated into the political
system their political wing is you know
pretty much holding the government now
they're you know they have two or three
other militant sort of organizations
which is which were Hindu Parishad and
Bajrang Dal which as per the CIA report
has been called as nationalist militant
organizations these organizations you
know with our penetrated across the
society now there are people there are
police officers there are elected
officials there are common people good
people there are journalists who are
taking a stance some people are able to
speak other people their voices are
suppressed
yeah and
this is the issue at hand that if you
have good and bad at the same time and
good people are able to speak to that's
part of any democracy I think I from my
perspective I may think something is not
good but at least there is a debate
there is a discussion there is you know
within the political landscape there is
a discussion and debate about it what's
happening in India is there is the other
voice that good people are bringing up
they are being squashed there that's an
issue because the reason I'm saying is
because you have a that's a human what's
the population of Hindus there it's
India's population is over a billion
right now yeah so if you have if you
have so many Hindus there if the good
people came out all of them and says
being quiet man they would overtake I
would think there was they would
overtake this evil and they would just
because the people's voice would be
heard and and now they would have to go
ahead and not they would not be allowed
to go this far excellent so see that's
what we like you know what I'm saying
like like we as Muslims as soon as some
lunatic does something it's like we have
to come condemn it even though it's
nothing do it Islam but now you got
people that are how many days did you
say a hundred a hundred days locked up
like animals yeah all right like animals
and the world UN what are they doing you
and I mean you and didn't question you
and did question I did what did question
I mean they passed out there they're
working that that's what we're working
that you see a lot of organizations
working through you and so pass you know
asking us to take action against this to
your point really nothing concrete has
been done everybody is saying this is
India's internal matter yeah but see
career is one thing but the rest of the
India right I'll take Gujarat as an
example okay Gujarat has entered the
state on the eastern side of India 2002
when our prime minister was the chief
minister of that state a massacre of
Muslims were down where thousands of you
know Muslims were killed and believe it
or not on lots of Hindus a majority of
the Hindus spoke against it
were not in favor of this carnage so
this is a prime example of how when this
massacre was done
Hindus came in support of the minorities
in this case specifically Muslims so
that voice is there now when the cases
were opened for mm after 2002 it was
Hindus who were fighting for justice for
these people and really because of the
of the you know massive power that they
have they were able to squash it
nobody was brought to account and as a
matter of fact the victims were blamed
that it was because of your fault that
you burnt this you know train you know
all of this Massacre happens so it's
just the same nationalistic supremacy
supremacist you know agenda that that
came about here and you know what what
is scary here what is very scary here is
that that 2002 Gujarat Massacre was that
a blueprint for what is being planned
for rest of India and that is very scary
now you have Aamir Khan Shah Rukh Khan
these are really big names right they
are in India yes what are they doing
taking selfies hanging out with Modi I
mean what's there there's some
controversy going on there because
they're supposed to be Muslim and are
they having a meeting saying hey Modi
what's going on we got to get these
people out there are they like
ambassadors to the cause of trying to
stop the impression is that what's going
on I think that's up for interpretation
yeah I'll give you my view on it yeah
III think Aamir Khan and Shahrukh Khan
these are these are good actors right I
mean they are very popular if they say
something the you know majority of India
I think they listen and that's probably
the reason they you know they were asked
to or they themselves took it well you
know we will not make a judgement on
their behalf but when they when they
went and took those selfies the message
that they're going to continue no trying
to give them meaning Modi and you know
the Prime Minister and this thought
process is that things are pretty cool
in India yeah nothing is happening
India is good there are no issue
with that that's the message that's
trying to be given out he got that my
take on it
that's what Amir Khan and the other khan
shahrukh khan shahrukh khan that's the
message you think that they're giving
that everything is cool but but is it
cool no it is not cool that's the thing
right I mean that's depends on what part
of India and this is this is weird this
is where we got to spend a few minutes
to think about this right depending on
what part of India you live you don't
see any issues if you are in the
southern part of India things are pretty
cool yeah are they are they from the
southern part there in Bombay which is
still okay there's things are not too
bad yeah no they're going state-by-state
you know you have Kashmir then you had
awesome
now awesome oh by the way is a different
major concern then awesome and then not
not inside of India the mob lynching
that's happening it's not happening too
much even though it's happening you know
sporadic sporadic ly across the country
it's it's pretty much you know the
northern side of India of which we hear
all the time so mob lynching in 21st
century and you still tell me the
country is cool I mean tell me how do
you how do you justify that people and
this is just not Muslim mind you there
are adults there are Christians who are
being you know oppressed and suppressed
here
the mob lynching when people are being
killed majority of India opposes that
there are cases when Hindus jump in the
middle and stop it yeah and then
unfortunately there are cases when
nobody does anything and people stand
and watch when you have hundreds
I'm not saying one or two cases across
the country when you have hundreds of
mob lynching cases how can you say
things are pretty cool in India no it's
not cool people is this verifiable the
hundreds oh absolutely this is you
Google that you will see viable reports
of all of this
uh-huh yeah I mean do you think Aamir
Khan and Shahrukh Khan today do they
have a responsibility as being people
who are that popular that famous or
their hands tied I I would say their
hands may be tied because look anybody
in India who speaks up I am talking
about IAS so this is civil services
India there are cases of very senior
officers who try to I give you an
example about 2002 Gujarat carnage there
was two police officers who were looking
to investigate this and they they're not
in the picture anymore they're
completely gone so their voices will be
suppressed if somebody speaks up and
somebody is powerful enough and if they
speak up their voices will be surprised
now talking about these two actors Aamir
Khan Shah Rukh Khan you know they they
they because they don't feel the pain
maybe they're things thinking things are
cool maybe their hands are tied
you know it could be either ways yeah
yeah
so the situation there also is that you
mentioned there are detention centers
being set up you talk about that oh god
that's that's the next painful story of
what's happening is on the western state
of Assam which is next to Bangladesh
there are about two million people
especially minorities and very
specifically Muslims what they're doing
is they are so in 21st century detention
centers just think about this if you are
a general normal American living in this
world
think about map lynching in 21st century
you think about a detention center in
21st century there is a construction in
progress right now I don't know what's
the percentage complete right now a few
months ago it would the walls were built
the foundation was done by now I I think
that this is happening as we speak this
is happening as we speak why for what so
they're what they're saying is these are
the word they use I will use the Hindi
word that they use they use the word
goose Padilla goose Padilla I will try
to translate that the people who have
intruded in the country so there's these
people came from Bangladesh as the claim
weight so it sounds like sale again
because Bhatia goes piteously phobia no
no it's nothing it's not nothing to do
with Islamophobia even though at the
forefront of all of this is Islam
it sounds like it but it's really
because the Kashmere attention centers
and the attack on Muslims it sounds like
I mean it does it's not Imam Khan the
President of Pakistan he actually he
connected this all to anti Islam
Islamophobia it is it is but in India
it's just not Islamophobia even though
Islamophobia is is the biggest part of
it it's it's this nationalistic you know
supremacist ideology which is against
the minorities which is against the
lower caste Hindus which is against
other Hindus who may not follow that
okay so it's even a broader scope but
Dannette and this this evil of
nationalism yes that's the driving force
behind this that's the that's the bull
with the horns now absolutely and then
these days you know Eddie
you used the word is no Islamic
terrorism then that's said you got a
green pass for everything and that's
what they're the world is using that's
what India started using that that's the
the pretext now that's being used excuse
to go ahead and justify these things
absolutely yeah that's all you that's
the card now you want you want to invade
a country a war on terror war on terror
equals war on Islam you know so this is
just the pretext that I'm using but
smart people are waking up I mean waking
up to that reality because like you like
you said the majority of people are good
people yes you know and but most people
are manipulated by the mass media
manipulation and the lies that are out
there being perpetuated so we need to
create awareness like this and let
people think for themselves don't let
the media and in this particular case we
don't get much news at all on the media
here on what's going on in India no no
and think about this if there was a
listen I'm just gonna use you know let's
say a good Jew somewhere in the world
was lynched just because of his religion
what would be the reaction across the
globe that's a good point
think about what Imran Khan said eight
million dogs and cats if they were in a
in a lockdown what would think yeah I
think about that right now is Muslims
blood cheap that's the question and and
unfortunately that's the
and we're at and then then you know you
know we're talking about Muslims but
keep in mind in India even though
Muslims are one of the biggest
minorities which are being persecuted
the lower caste Hindus are going through
the same thing the Dalits Christians are
going through the same thing so this is
not again I will repeat one more time
this is not a Hindu most versus Muslim
thing because I don't want anybody to
misinterpret this this is the
supremacist ideology the nationalistic
militant ideology against the good
people yeah just imagine because people
they love their pets here and in our
country here and people love their dogs
you know imagine if they took that
beloved dog locked them up and you got 8
million people's dogs or cats whatever
locked up imagine what kind of uproar
that would be the citizens would have
yeah but the world sleeps and the you
know I you know I when I was in Bosnia
and many people compared it this is I
got this news sometime back that what
they're speaking to the average India
and they were telling me
I'll ask what's going on in India and
they know that my backgrounds from from
Bosnia and they would say what happened
in Bosnia it's slowly they're trying
they're trying to prepare what could
potentially be a genocide so we heard
this dis word being thrown around
potential genocide that could happen in
Iran Khan he said a good like what's
gonna happen when you have 8 million
people when now you know you have caged
them like animals what's gonna happen
now you keep on putting the pressure
pressure pressure and then you release
and now what's gonna happen yeah that's
a scary part yeah that's a scary part
and he he made some really good some
points in his really recommend people
see his UN United Nations speech and and
the term because what happened there in
Bosnia is that we came to know I didn't
make this up the soldiers there who were
on the ground and they saw that the
United Nations wasn't doing anything to
stop the genocide that was happening
against the Muslims in Bosnia and
Muslims simply just any human being who
has submitted his or her will to the
crater that heavens an earth wants a
little peaceful life with their Creator
with themselves
and their neighbors so they were writing
on the on the walls their United Nations
basically they were putting United
nothing because they did nothing right
they actually helped the tufa they
helped in the facilitation the Dutch
solders I believe the Dutch soldiers
soldiers in helping the the mat the the
mass genocide over 8,000 innocent souls
in seven isa you know about that yes
yeah so now we see we're trying to
create awareness because it's it's seems
like now you can have a greater genocide
here that's gonna happen in Kashmir
there and Assam and and could you out
they did it they did it for a few
thousand people yeah in Gujarat and
that's the blueprint that we are really
scared that they are looking to take it
across the country and and and if
somebody there's if there are people who
are going to deny that that is implants
let me quote the Home Minister of India
who was the architect of the genocide in
Gujarat yeah the Home Minister of India
has said that we will give citizenship
to all religions he took a name
categorically of all religions except
Muslims and they said the people who are
going to have to prove their citizenship
or goose Padilla is the word he used
so anybody all are the religions they're
going to be given citizenship the only
religion he did not mention who are
going to be given citizenship is Muslims
now who's saying this this is the Home
Minister of India the humanist woman who
holds the power of the country he's
saying that everyone is gonna begin
Assam so he said so basically just to
give me take a step back real quick very
quick this nr seen a national
citizenship registry right
what this is is they want to make a
registry of citizens but in theory
there's not wrong with that right every
country should have it but if only
minorities are going to be targeted and
in this case only Muslims are going to
be targeted we have a problem with that
if and that's where they're saying that
anybody who is not a Muslim we're gonna
give them citizenship so they're not
going to be you know target of any of
this and then the detention centers
they're building it's only Muslims who
are going to be in those desert
centers and that is on the record
anybody can google and they can find it
Gandhi at his time was he fighting
against people like this absolutely so
one thing I want to say now India this
mentality this nationalistic supremacist
er mentality I'm talking about
they were the killers of Gandhi okay so
Gandhi was the face of India the whole
time now the people who killed Gandhi
unfortunately are in power today so the
people who killed Gandhi now these other
people were trying to kill Muslims yes
the same people same people thank you so
they're gonna kill Aamir Khan and sugar
I hope not but if you're a Muslim you're
a target if you're a minority if you're
done it to your question you could be a
target that's that part uh-huh but it's
got it's gotten is it gotten that bad
I'm just trying to think because usually
if you have like Hollywood stars here
they're usually not scared to speak
they'll get up and they'll support like
you know something that's cool to
support or sometimes some are brave
enough to come out but with the you're
comparing the world's most free country
to you know but it's not isn't India
it's supposed to be a free country which
is still is do and they got bought they
have over there Bollywood yes yeah yes
but if I was sitting in India and if you
were to interview me like this I think
I'd be scared to say what some of the
things that I said here do people go
missing I mean what are they some parts
of India yes they do go missing so again
this is where you have to you have to
understand and appreciate the diversity
of India India is a large country some
parts of India are still pretty safe to
a large majority it's still pretty safe
they're going state-by-state Gujarat was
the first target they successfully did
what they wanted to do they massacred
where now people of Gujarat you know
they're not second-class citizens the
Muslims but but really they don't they
they don't have the same opportunities
like everybody else in the country now
now they went after Kashmir the next is
Assam what is next you with the Pradesh
the state of you P their chief minister
is god help us I mean he is a his
extreme beyond what you can imagine so
they're going to
by state so people in other states don't
even know what's happening they're too
busy or making their own livelihood they
don't know they don't appreciate the
plants who appreciate do speak up the
ones who don't appreciate they're just
too busy that they're left you tried
it's interesting people try to attack
Islam and attack Muslims but in what we
have you can equate let's say the
Constitution in the divine legislation
of Islam and Islam simply means to
submit your will to the creator of the
heavens on earth so in its legislation
you have guaranteed rights that no
people could come across in a majority
you know
outrun the minority or whatnot like like
we see happening here just you gotta
guess like this gang mentality you got a
whole group of racist nationalists right
and now they're coming together and then
the they end up changing laws and
oppressing the the minority but in Islam
the divine legislation that we have you
have people who are not Muslim but they
have rights yes and you can't oppress
these people absolutely and and and look
and everybody and they want to attack
Islam exactly and in the sea that's the
beauty that's the irony of the thing
it's the beauty of the thing is the
irony of the thing let me show you what
am I mean by that is Lomb brings all of
these you know just simple basic human
rights to the forefront I think
similarly all of the religions do when
it comes to the core competency but when
Muslim violates some of this it's on the
highlight other people do it they get a
free pass yeah that's that's tyranny of
the situation that's not that's that's
the irony because you have this is not
just this place then you have you know
with the extremist Buddhists who are
doing in Myanmar right India here
Kashmir you have all these different
places Palestine and now the world
sleeps and it seems like like you said
those people who are submissive to their
Creator their blood is cheap but that's
the test you know my God Almighty make
it make it easy but inshallah what what
can what can people do what can what
does the organization what do you guys
now
you have an event coming up also with
viewit medicine yeah and what can people
do to help to alleviate some of the
suffering some of the pain some of the
crit more awareness what what can people
do so few things here right first and
foremost I think what I would ask each
and every person who is listening here
educate yourself find out what is
happening on the ground get some on the
ground reality that's number one number
two have a discussion on this talk to
your elected officials if you you know
tell them because keep in mind if we all
see this genocide coming but at the same
time a genocide or some kind you know
this kind of violence cannot be stopped
from inside because they will be
squashed it has to be stopped from
outside and this is where I think what
people can do is your question I think
people should first educate themselves
second make their elected officials
aware of what is happening because there
is so much life in the National mean you
know news and the media you don't see
any of this it's up to the individuals
to educate themselves and then promote
this pluralism and you know the secular
country that India once was so the card
that they're using now because to get
away with this you have to have some
strategy and some some some words that
you're using you know some pretext it's
all that these are these people are
threat they're terrorists what are they
saying that's exactly what they're
saying this this is a threat to the
country and which you know one of the
key things that we do is we build
coalitions we work with other Hindus we
work with Dalits where you know the
lower caste Hindus we work with six
we've worked at Christians and we work
with Brahmins the higher caste Hindus
their majority I don't like I said are
good and we're working with them there
are several organizations that we are
working with kind of trying to work and
you know promote this pluralistic
culture that India you know should be
and has always been until you know
recently and and this is the work since
1925 when RSS was established you're
seeing the fruits of it come in the last
six five six ten years
that's where if people educate
themselves now people you know find out
the facts and that's where I think the
results you will see in a few years now
you ask me you know what an individual
can do right if you're in the
Chicagoland area we have an event coming
up November 16th with Madison please
join us so this event is November 16th
at 6 p.m. at Shalimar banquets in LA
work well a few more questions before we
conclude tell us so Imran Khan the
president of Pakistan he he came out in
his speech and first he addressed he
dressed many things and then he he
finished it off I believe with the
Kashmir issue in India and that and he
talked about he talked about Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he gave examples through his his history
of some of the noble things that he
amazing things he did he cleared up some
misconceptions and he I like what he did
because he went to the root of the
problem and this is the people being
anti Muslim anti Islam and then he also
talked about the potential war between
that can happen that will spill over and
that's my question to you what's going
on now with Pakistan and and India is
Pakistan do they are they a strong force
to be reckoned with if is there the
possibility for them to collide look any
country with with nuclear power I think
is a power to reckon with
now take the politic you know the the
nuclear power out of the equation even
then those two countries regardless of
who wins who loses the destruction in
the region would be beyond what Minds
can know first us here everybody is
going it will affect the entire globe
yeah I mean the the the repercussions
the results could be damaging to the
entire world I mean this is in the best
interest of the entire world to bring
back India to its core values of
pluralism to its core values of
secularism because if India and Pakistan
collide in this case and now the
forefront is the issue there is Kashmir
if
real issue is not resolved and there's a
collision as you said the the the
progressions repercussions would be
beyond what mine can imagine because of
the modern day you know weaponry both
countries have you had the President of
Pakistan who was trying he's made it
clear that he never wants to go to war
with anybody he's a he's a man of peace
and he was trying to extend that hand of
peace to the President of India and it
he talks about how they took that as a
sign of weakness
yeah and they even I believe Trump tried
to mediate and they wanted no part of
that they didn't come to the they didn't
want to come to the table to make that
happen is that right yes and what we
need to understand there is this
government this ideology feeds off of
hate if there is peace with Pakistan
then they lose their government goes
away tomorrow because they're
economically they're doing really bad
right now under this government you know
the the previous prime minister of India
he took India to new heights I mean he
did a lot of good things he was the
finance minister prior to that so from
from an economic perspective
he took India to new heights I mean he
did a lot of good things for India all
of the work you see being undone right
now even though you know some people of
this ideology may like to think that
India is growing because just because
you know what happened here in in
Houston howdy Modi event right when when
Modi comes here you know you see all of
these activities happening and people
think that oh the all things are good so
that's where that's where I think this
whole ideology to hold this mentality
feeding off of hate in India will be
taken aback if there is peace with
Pakistan I don't think I don't think the
current government would want that what
about the was it 13,000 young boys who
are abducted from their families in
Kashmir
that is correct it wasn't it by the way
his name was Manmohan Singh sorry it
just slipped my mind but yes there are
13,000 boys who reportedly are missing
there are reports of thousands and
thousands of women being raped
so these report
are out there where's the feminist
movement where the worth is are they
coming through for their sisters there
and now in Kashmir no nobody speaks
because see India is denying that yeah
and and the reports that are coming out
of India the the mass media is really
not they let reporters from here on the
ground to come in no sir there are no
reporters no international I told you
right as soon as soon as that happened
you closed the door from people coming
in yeah now you know that all these
things there obviously why don't they
want them in yeah there are no
international reporters allowed
international politicians elected
officials wanted to go to Kashmir they
were not allowed now somebody will
immediately counter this how do the
counter there that they did allow
actually invite some far-right
politicians from Europe EU and then they
took them to Kashmir which I've my
opinion was a blunder mistake you're
actually showing to the world
that you are this exact same supremacist
mentality when a normal American
politician wants to go there you're not
allowing them from your politicians from
UK try to go there you're not allowing
them and then you're going to hand pick
who you want to take there that I think
it itself is a proof that you are a
supremacist organization are there a lot
of Americans from politicians from here
speaking up about it
and there are a few there are a few who
are speaking against it and they they
they you know if you if you were to hear
the in October there was a congressional
hearing and there they questioned India
again as to hey what is happening and as
an outside country I think that's to the
extent they can do and and I think a lot
of politicians are bringing this up and
and the the way I hope each and every
elected officials here brings that up
especially the ones were part of the you
know foreign policy but some people
might get confused it's a hold on if
it's so bad then why is like a country
in the Middle East you know giving
awards to someone like this president if
he was doing something so bad you know
about that
you absolutely in and then this is this
is the irony of the situation again
right
our own elected officials they don't
care for the wider Muslim community they
don't care about human rights for them
it's about their seat it's about their
personal games about their business with
India they don't want to impact their
business with India so they are
basically you know following along along
in this whole narrative and they're not
taking a stance and that's where when
you are our own leaders are like that we
have nothing or no other choice but
accept to ourself stand up and do the
best we can which is you know kind of
educate people around us what do you
think would happen if we went on the
streets to davonne Avenue yes
and we asked if a lot of Hindus over
there yeah if we ask the average Hindu
their take on what's going on in Kashmir
what do you what do you think their
response would be an average Hindu I
think keep in mind and the the their
thought process would be that if you if
they are educated enough to understand
that this was the Indian Constitution I
think they will clearly say that Indian
Constitution was violated now if you
were to ask an average Joe who may not
know the the background the fundamentals
they would say hey it was part of India
India is saying there's one article we
were going to remove but if you look at
the background there is so much more to
it so I think I would say depends on who
you ask that your response would be
different somebody who is like I said
the grandson of Gandhi yeah you know he
himself being a Hindu clearly said the
voice of the people of Kashmir was not
taken into account which was at the
fundamental at the core of article 370
that any decision that is made for
Kashmir will be based upon the decision
taken by the people of Kashmir yeah
Gandhi being known for his nonviolent
protests he had such great things to say
about Prophet Muhammad peace and must be
upon him he was reading his history and
then when it came to an end from
whatever he read he was talking about
how how he wished that there was more
that you know and he praised he was
actually praising prophet muhammad's I'm
supposed to be a father yeah yeah you
know how India is known
I'm using this example because India
across the globe is view that is not
violent peaceful secular country which
is a Christian and I hope peoples within
India and outside India can stop this
agent mm-hmm so thank you very much I
think that you know this is something
that for us all of us you know
especially here we have so many
blessings to be grateful for and you you
start to seeing the different tests that
are going on and we can make dua for our
brothers and sisters in these parts and
it reminds us to hold tight to the Rope
of Allah to the Creator to be committed
to our Deen you know because if we try
to find solace and peace and anything
anybody else then the Creator that
happens in the earth and I mean that's
what we're going to have big issues so
we need to be you know come back to the
basics come back to the basis of Dien
hold on to the Dean and know that this
life is short yes it's transitory as a
test and inshallah we pass and get to
Jenna and shallow that's where the real
home is thank you so much thank you for
having me on me way up and thank you
guys for tuning in you go ahead
subscribe if you haven't check us out on
our patreon page also we can support our
work and we'll see you next time here
every week on the Deen show until then
peace be with you
assalamu alaikum